Will and Grace is back every Friday at
and o'clock and I mean it's one of those
things you know we knew would it be in a
way but then you know 11 years was it
really 11 years and the method of it
coming back is so bizarre that no one
was talking about it coming back to was
well yeah so go on
no um you know I I had been campaigning
for Hillary Clinton and we were talking
about about trying to help her and then
it turned out that our entire set had
been stored pristinely on the college
campus of our executive producer for ten
years Emerson College about Emerson
College and then they got a call and
said we need you to move the entire set
to storage we need to do some fixes and
so he realized I have the entire set of
Will and Grace maybe there's something I
can do with it and that's when he wrote
the four of us and said maybe what do
you guys want to do a seven-minute
little little film on YouTube to try and
help Hillary and within 10 minutes all
four of us had said yes and we came back
and we did it and we really thought it
was going to be just a one-off and we
said goodbye and we were like oh my god
how lucky 10 years later we got to play
with each other again and then you know
seven and a half million views and they
were like wait a second flew the entire
set piece by piece across the country at
his own expense was really expensive and
we did this thing entirely in secret
nobody knew except our few crew members
even the B nobody knew even people that
showed up that I was a invited audience
of about a hundred people weren't told
what they were about to see and when and
when the curtain parted and it was that
set and the four of us in costume it was
it was very awesome because it came from
a pro Hillary place when Trump won that
put you all
okay well ten minutes didn't work what
about if we do a whole season that was
rough
yeah weird it's still more rough than
ever it's embarrassing to be here from
America at the moment but refreshing
nice to be here the the idea that if
Hillary had one and we could have taken
some small credit we just if we had come
back but now it feels like we're the
resistance somehow and in terms of you
know restarting it kind of rebooting it
how much discussion was around you know
because you ended up in that last
episode you know you ended up in a very
different place to where you started
this serious oh yeah we had kids it was
25 years in the future and then we're
like well how are we gonna do this and
they're like oh the first scene of the
first series is the ninth series that
which just started here basically we
wrote the whole thing off as a dream the
idea of willing grace having kids and
making the whole show about that was
like can we just be gay
[Music]